The MTG Fallout collaboration is
launching with two products, collector
boosters and Commander decks. Now,
whether you're new to Magic or a
returning player, it can be hard to know
which product you should be picking up
on launch day. So, let's go over the
options and which Fallout product you
should grab. Quickly crunching some
numbers, we know that this Fallout set
contains to Magic Fallout
inspired cards and approximately 180
reprinted Magic cards with brand new
Fallout inspired artwork along with some
double ups scattered between the decks.
The four Commander decks are a 100 card
singleton deck, meaning there is only
one copy of each card inside the deck
aside from basic lands.
The cards in this deck will only be the
colors of the front-facing commander or
colorless.
So, for example, the Dogmeat deck,
Scrappy Survivors, the cards inside will
be red, white, green, colorless, or some
combination of them. As well as the
deck, you'll get a sample collector
booster pack which will come with two
random Fallout cards. As far as how many
new Fallout cards you get in each deck,
it looks like this. The Scrappy
Survivors deck, helmed by Dogmeat ever
loyal, comes with 38 new cards and is
currently retailing for about 50 US
dollars. In the Mutant Menace deck,
helmed by the wise Mothman, you get 41
new cards and this is currently
retailing for about 60 US dollars.
The Hail Caesar deck, helmed by Caesar
Legion's emperor, comes with 37 new
cards and is currently retailing for
about 60 US dollars as well.
And Science, helmed by Dr. Madison Li,
it comes with 38 new cards and is
currently retailing for about 50 US
dollars. So, going based off new cards
alone, your best bang for buck is
clearly Mutant Menace which comes with
the most brand new Fallout cards. But,
this is only by a small margin, so I
would still simply recommend picking up
your favorite looking deck. We'll talk
more about the Commander decks in more
detail in another video. So, let's jump
into the next commonly asked question,
what are the Fallout collector boosters
all about and should I get them too?
Now, to make things really clear, the
Fallout collector boosters do not come
with any extra new Fallout cards outside
of the four Commander decks, meaning if
you did happen to pick up all four
Commander decks, you will own a copy of
every single new Fallout Magic card as
well as the reprints with the new
Fallout art.
Collector boosters are for bling out
your decks.
Collector boosters are the best and only
place to get these new Fallout cards in
foil as well as collecting the
additional nine Vault Boy styled
reprints in this classic Fallout style
art,
26 Pip-Boy treatment cards, as well as
extended art versions of the Commander
cards.
There's also a chance you can open up
one of seven bobblehead cards featuring
serialization on only 500 copies each.
These serialized versions will also
feature a special double rainbow foil
treatment. Inside each collector pack,
you get 15 playable cards and one
double-sided foil token.
Of those 15 cards, seven to 14 of them
will be rare or mythic, up to seven of
them will be uncommon, and up to five of
them will be common.
You'll also get one full art land,
either the isometric version or the
Vault Wanderers journey.
Now, you know what's inside a collector
booster, keep in mind that these are
currently retailing for about 24 US
dollars per pack.
And a collector booster box, which
contains 12 packs, will set you back
about 280 US dollars.
So, which product should you be picking
up?
Personally, I think the best thing you
can do is simply grab the four Commander
decks.
Not only will you get literally all of
the Fallout cards being printed, you'll
also be picking up some excellent
Commander staples if you decide to take
one of the decks apart.
Collector boosters are generally for
those written on the pack,
collectors. Sure, it's nice to foil out
one of your Commander decks, but for
half the price of one of the Fallout
precons, it just doesn't seem worth it
to me.
I'm just going to wait for singles to
drop at my LGS and pick them up in a
month or so.
So, that's everything you need to know
about the two main products for the
Fallout MTG set.
What will you be picking up?
As always, be sure to like the video if
you learned something. And if you would
like a plus one to one of your special
stats, be sure to subscribe.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next one.